[Music] Mr. Claude It must be a white school It's a
prestigious school
Even the demon king was wondering what to do if a stone was thrown It
's almost
time for the next meeting No
, I want to know the inside of the school
I need to prepare for Assart's attack
I can't attack
anything There is no monster that can match the king Bell Do
n't throw away your preconceptions and think You
can
do it Come to think of it, there's
something I want to ask Is there a duck student at this school
?  Is it alright? Ah, if it's
not lunchtime yet, the headmaster will show you to the
cafeteria.
[Music]
Serena
must be longing for the maiden of the government, right?
Uh, that's fine, but
I'm begging you, Serena, can you
guide me? Yes, I'll leave
it to you
.
[music]
That face is still insane, but